my heart went out to the people that
produced this stuff and all of our bad
times but especially or fine orchestras
and then dancers people that do that and
you I just amazed at what you people do
and how you express it it's art and love
and design and movement it's beautiful
and that's so cool that y'all got to do
the father I thought that was really
special what book did we tell that
whatever that book you read yeah it was
literally called Misty Copeland I had a
book that I read when I was like just
saw her backstage in the look on her
face she's like I was like oh my gosh
there's somebody we didn't know that
every morning like I would I was I don't
know probably like seven or eight years
old and my mom and I used to read books
like while she was making breakfast and
I had it was just like you know picture
books like a kid's picture book but I
read it every morning like every morning
so when when I heard I was like
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]